attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
allez les gars on y voit là
brainstorming d'accord n'a rien foutu un
quoi vous voulez dire - une habitude
chaque fois que passe la moniliose et
sur facebook
ah non parce qu'on essaie de voler des
idées aux amériques et en fait en plus
ou moins longue mais je comprends rien
les gars au café merci nana bascule à
son patron s'est crashé dans about
hommes
je prendrai qu'un ok alors le premier
dossier on est en compétition pour une
pub pour un fromage qui pue le sahb
renâcle là je sais on prend un paysan ça
marche toujours
ouais enfin c'est fabriqué dans une
usine en pologne on s'en fout on prend
un vieux paysan avec une grosse
moustache et les mains sales et on
réinvente des camions et s'est vautré
les armes
non c'est celle du stagiaire et comme il
a dit la machine à café et qu'il ait
jamais habito réunion je me suis dis moi
où aller piquer ok alors on a aussi un
gros problème avec la pulpe thé brick au
maxi elle est complètement pourri
si quelqu'un a une idée pour nous sortir
de là ça sera super bon on fait comme
d'habitude on pousse le son à fond
c'est complètement con ne peut pas faire
ça mais non c'est pas complètement con
les gens ils sont enfin de cité
tranquille ou d'un coup il se met à
discuter à la pub haribo leçon à bâle
il sursaute il écoute la pub et là c'est
gagné
bravooo belles idées de merde par
ailleurs oui on arrive d'hypermarchés
qui veut faire parler de lui alors il se
cherche un nouveau slogan percutant
moderne qui dégagerait des ondes
positives
eh ben on n'a qu'à créer un bon c'est à
dire mais on invente un verbe on fait
une faute de français on s'en fou comme
ça les gens ils vont avoir le doute et
paf
voilà gens mais je sais pas jamais
lloris mme jamet lloris mme pas mal
intéressant 1 mais franchement si ça
marche ça c'est fort hein parce que
c'est bien con quand même et pour finir
on a un gros budget pour un gel douche
bon comment les l'accord sur le concept
une meuf à poil devant lui
[Musique]